les femmes elles mènent un mouvement de
résistance face au régime taliban elles
ont ouvert des écoles clandestine pour
éduquer les filles même si le régime
l'interdit
de se battre dit-il elles ont besoin de
notre soutien
et l'une de ces résistantes pour
survivre et la mise sur pied une petite
entreprise d'artisanat à Kaboul mais ce
n'est pas grâce à la diplomatie et la
pluie parvenir c'est vers une autre
femme qu'elle s'est tournée pour obtenir
du soutien au boycott il sort des vidéos
il y a plus de 20 ans a fondé le Centre
des femmes afghane de Montréal
femmes talentueuses et nous voulons
faire de l'artisanat et le vendredi au
bazar pour soutenir nos familles
les fonds nécessaires oui samedi
cet argent je le prends directement de
ma poche j'ai un peu d'économie je suis
heureuse d'aider les gens je pourrais le
garder mais cet argent est bien plus
utile comme ça
c'est aussi parce qu'elle a perdu
confiance dans les solutions
diplomatiques et particulièrement dans
la mission d'assistance de l'ONU là-bas
les Nations Unies ne peuvent pas
vraiment aider le nu a beaucoup de
pouvoir mais elle n'écoute pas elle se
fait de la publicité
j'aimerais ça que Canada portent leur
aide et doit avoir en entendre avec ce
régime Victoria jarret a pris la relève
de mikaï à la tête du Centre des femmes
afghane de Montréal au point situation
on est rendu elle se demande si la
solution n'est pas de tendre la main au
régime je pense que c'est exactement il
faut qu'il y ait une diplomatie
certaines d'une manière
rester avec l'Italie bon qu'est-ce qu'il
veut
c'est quoi leur entendre puis comment on
peut par exemple sauver les peuples
innocentes qui présentement ils sont
visés envers la situation les crises
militaire crise économique
de retour à l'ambassade Assan suroche
lui continue d'y croire
en attendant on va continuer tant et
aussi longtemps que l'on pourra offrir
des services consulaires à la communauté
afghan du Canada qui ne cesse de
s'agrandir c'est une obligation morale
dit-il
le jour viendra où les femmes
retrouveront leurs droits et leurs voies
dit à samso Roche parce que le régime ne
pourra pas survivre sans être reconnu et
pas seulement sur la scène
internationale mais d'abord et avant
tout par les Afghans eux-mêmes ici
Valérie Gama che au Canada
Ottawa